c'est en 2018 que le groupe espagnol
mediapro réalisé un gros coup en france
en s'emparant d'une partie des droits
des matches de ligue 1 et ligue 2 un
groupe qui n'a pas de chaîne dans
l'hexagone pour diffuser ses matches
tout le monde se demandait donc quelle
serait sa stratégie pour exploiter ces
retransmissions et c'est tf1 qui vient
de répondre à cette question en conclure
un accord exclusif avec mediapro en
effet la chaîne privée lance en
partenariat avec mediapro la chaîne télé
foot une nouvelle antenne sur laquelle
seront diffusés l'ensemble des matches
achetés par le géant espagnol du sport
grégoire margotton et bixente lizarazu
les deux visages du foot sur tf1 seront
aussi ceux de cette nouvelle chaîne
si cet accord permet à mediapro de
sauver les meubles et d'éviter de perdre
tout bénéfice de la diffusion des
matches de ligue 1 et ligue 2 en france
les autres chaînes du groupe tf1 ne
seront pas en mesure de diffuser
gratuitement l'intégralité ou des
extraits de ces compétitions dans
téléfoot ce qui ne sera pas gratuit long
plus c'est l'accès à cette chaîne
mediapro et tf1 ont décidé de fixer le
prix de l'abonnement à téléfoot à 25
euros par mois alors qui va payer 25
balles pour voir des matchs de ligue 1
jean michel qui est un grand fan de foot
dis moi tu me battre jamais de l'ami
jamais la démo si jamais d'être papa
jamais de la vie non et pourtant vous
avez les moyens donc imaginé cette
langue passionné qui on a les moyens en
chemin sort d'une crise sanitaire les
gens sont au chômage dans les 25 balles
impossibles j'ai le plus cher c'est le
truc le plus cher d'eau qui hier s'est
éteint à un déferlement j'ai un habit
noir rmc sport be in canal maintenant il
en fut en plus la ligue 1 c'est
tellement à deux jours 25 euros par mois
c'est trop cher quand tu vois ce que
propose been pour moins de 15 euros
non mais vous rendez compte du prix à
payer sur le warthog foot à la télé been
15 bal rmc sport 20 euros eurosport 9
euros mediapro 25 euros canal+ pack
sport 40 euros selon les compétences
mathématiques sur développer sa fin un
total de 109 euros par mois pour dufour
maison mère n'est pas moins par les
bills quand vous parlez de binh des
races des rams et sport vous parlez de
ligue des champions la thèse n'y a pas
de nick des choix pas qu'on n'a pas et
on sait là les galeries sont là des
champions les passionnés cpg marseille
et geignant lyon om c'est que sarkozy
aux vernets de 21 2022
vous le savez que la ligue rennes on
revient sur canal plus mal 2021-2022
2022 2023 2023 2024
et ouais donc voila et mais c'est la
première libre vers les prochaines sur
canal mais c'est vrai que payer 25
balles à pour faire
oh la la la la ligue 1 c'est
complètement fou pense que vraiment ils
voient ce modèle économique alors je
vous dirai ça marche
mais si ça marche vraiment s'il arrive à
tenir à tenir je vous le dis je je
quadruple vos salaires a et on donnera
tout cela bien sûr arriver même avec
vous mais moi je sais moi aussi je
comprends pas de sitôt ici n'est pas
possible que ça fait leur travail
incroyable de miser sur peu d'abonnés
entendu qu'on va faire l'abonnement cher
parce qu'on aura peu d'abonnés au lieu
de faire un abonnement pas chez moi je
vous dirais je pense que ça a été plus
je le dis franchement j'ai dit aux
téléspectateurs plus un truc d'orgueil
et de se dire on veut absolument essayer
de passer devant bid et devant canal que
un truc vraiment financier mais là
aujourd'hui on a vu ce qu'ils
demandaient jusqu'à demander et vu ce
que ça coûte et bim et canal non il n'y
ont pas été alors ont bien fait parce
que créer une chaîne et en plus la
rigolade you dare dare y est énorme
c'est que dans l'émission téléfoot de
tf1
ils pourront pas diviser les extraits de
ligue 1 ça veut dire c'est quand même
passer la crise il faut être fou lancé
le patron fourie sophie aime et c'est
surréaliste d'avoir une stratégie
marketing qui serait basée sur l'orgueil
enfin j'veux dire ça n'a pas de sens
soit les mecs qui sont là pour faire de
l'oseille
j'ai pas l'impression que les supporters
de foot a fait que je me trompe mais
j'ai plutôt l'impression que les gens
ont pas un salaire de dengue en fan est
nommé de personnes n'était pas très
clair mais le foot c'est populaire ya
des gens qu'on s'est révélé comme le
foot et des gencives à l'argent si vous
aimez le foot et au moins on aimerait
tous se voir on va tout vous dire moi je
rêve de revoir les matchs de foot non
payant à l'époque mais c'est vrai il
faudrait boycotter cette proposition-là
de tf1 réalisation qui seraient obligés
de baisser les prix si on ne s'est
enrichie d'accord d'accord 25 balles
c'est pas possible on va voir regarder
le sondage choqué 90
à choquer 10% le coût 25 euros par mois
force est le plus populaire qui soit
mais bien sûr on est relisez pour en
revenir à ce que vous avez dit vous avez
parlé que tf1 par orgueil et c'est le
gagnant là dedans c'est pas tes fins et
mediapro parce que mediapro il avait
rien là il était nu aucune la chaîne
elle n'existait même pas et oui mais oui
mais mettez trop je vous dire aussi et
je le dis c'est de l'aider japon sont
arrivés ils sont ils sont arrivés ils
ont donné des chiffres et après ils sont
dix comment on va faire il va rester ça
des milliards comment on va faire
maintenant pour s'en sortir donc sur les
voir tout le monde
ils sont ils y croient et mais je pense
franchement mis nos médias prompts à
voir mais si la chaîne tomber si la
chaîne des faillites il s'associe à
l'arrêt de cette chaîne et fait toujours
qu'on a un riche espagnole qui a monté
ça rien du tout et consultant canal ils
ont été re signer donc tu peux pas les
l'étape et tu vas aller taper des
consultants des rams et sport parce que
il veut forcément ils ont rompu taf donc
tu vas aller taper des consultants l'un
de ces sports mais ont remonté sa
debrief avec miki débrouya avec de
losail bancaire et bric et de broc